Julie's in Austin Texas hi Julie welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show I did thank you
so very much for taking my call I'm
overly nervous
maybe bear with me no trouble never lost
a patient how can we help is there an
age where you consider people too old to
get started
my husband's about 260 I'm about to hit
54 he is really not very enthused about
starting this program what things can I
do to help us and if need be are there
things that you ever recommend a wife
can try to do on her own now truth be
told my husband's distrustful of my
financial desire we got burned because
of the decisions in the past that I
promoted and so he has reasons to be
cautious so I'll just shut up and let
you ask questions what'd you get burned
on we sold stocks and inherited before
y2k that has grown hugely of course when
we no longer owned it right that
portfolio would have would be huge now
we put emergency fund in to wait too
small at home that some money think and
then the bedroom Edition that we put on
made up the emergency fund that we had
back then I'm sorry man where was he
when all these decisions were being made
you made them by yourself without him
know so why why is it your fault I think
that he feels like in order to make me
happy and or to keep the peace he did
things that he didn't feel good in his
gut about okay so his problem is not his
problem is not your decisions his
problem is is that he needs to run down
to Walmart and pick up a spine and stand
up this man up to you what do you think
doing something wrong is really fine and
honorable man and I don't know he know I
didn't question his honor or how fine he
was I said you said he didn't stand up
to you when he knew you all were doing
something wrong and now he blames you
that's what you told me didn't you I
don't think I want to go there I feel
like he's he's had to persist in a job
that he hates for so long he sacrificed
so much that he's not looking maybe into
an austerity program to help us kind of
maybe make more progress yeah okay no no
there is not a program that a wife can
do without her husband that's going to
do anything so caused problems the
people all the data points we have of
people who are able to build wealth and
able to build financial stability all
come from couples learning to work
together and trust each other's wisdom
and Sharron and I disagree often or a
couple of hillbillies disagreement is a
way of life okay we it's just it's how
we process decisions we have to fight
about them sometimes and we're fine with
that when I'm mad about each other we
don't lose trust over it but we argue
about paint color on the wall for God's
sakes and so but but that's how we
process decisions but we don't either
one of us move forward against the other
ones will and that has caused us to
prosper we can have it we can have a
discussion we can have a passionate
discussion you could call it a fight we
can have all of those things but we're
going to be an agreement before we move
forward an agreement is not one of us
caving because the other one is ashamed
that I've worked so hard or some other
kind of crap like that this is we're
gonna be two adults looking into the
future and we both feel good about the
decisions and we're gonna make those
decisions together all the data points
say that kind of a relationship is about
the only situation that wealth is built
in occasionally someone makes so much
thinking money they can overcome the
toxic relationships in their life but
most of the time the toxic relationships
are a bigger deal breaker than income a
bigger deal breaker than that a bigger
deal breaker than other stuff and so the
two of you learning to respect each
other learning to work together learning
to communicate
well and not I'm gonna give you a pass
because you work a job you hate not I'm
not gonna go there not yeah we're going
there we're going there and you know if
you were my little sister and you are
I'm 58 so and he's only my slightly big
brother then you know I would just sit
down with you and say guys you're number
one impediment to getting your financial
act together is the way you deal with
each other you've got some toxic garbage
going on in your relationship he let you
do things he didn't think were good and
then he has the unmitigated gall to say
he doesn't trust your financial
decisions when he was involved in them
when you're involved in the decision you
don't get to say I told you so you lost
that card you don't get to play that
card and that's what's going on here so
you guys can't work our stuff until you
get your marriage stuff straightened out
so I would tell you to sit down with a
good pastor and work on the stuff and
know no one is ever too old if you're
breathing you're not too old to get
smarter if you're breathing you're not
too old to get wiser if you're breathing
you're not too old to do better at any
given area of your life as a matter of
fact the most vibrant old people you
ever run into are the ones that are
continual learners they're always trying
something new they're adventurous
they're not stuck they're not sitting on
their recliner waiting to die and so
these are the best and the coolest old
people you ever run into be one of those
that's what we all want to be I think
sometimes it's hard to do but so you
guys have an adventure ahead of you
you've got a whole new chapter in your
marriage that you need to discover and
then that'll lead you to some much
better chapters in your financial world
that you can discover and that's what I
hope for you